hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we have tons of more
information on season four characters
all that obviously all the new gear the
weapons the ornaments and new executions
that have just dropped recently so we
have tons of new information we need to
talk about so let's get right into this
around wasting any time on this so first
up is the weekly content and these are
new executions that are be coming that
are going to be coming in in season four
we've been waiting so long for these I
have to show you these so I'm going to
play that video right now let's get
started
[Music]
[Music]
so those are the executions those are
gonna be costing 7,000 steel each those
were [ __ ] beautiful
they were bloody and they were amazing
Ubisoft really outdid themselves on
these they're just so good
can't say were cut in the arm off
conquer decapitate in the dudes arm
shoo go key so mashing the dude's head
with just his hands that's crazy but
these were just beautifully executed so
shout out to Ubisoft for that but anyway
let's continue on now we're gonna be
talking about the new characters as well
as the stuff that they're gonna be
coming with upon season 4 release so
first up we have our a Musha and
according to his description ARA Musha
uses his blades for offense and defense
and moves very quickly using his fast
dodges he is a fast and counter attacker
and some of his special capabilities are
infinite chains probably similar to
berserkers chain as well as very good
dodge and block moves probably like a
deflect and I'm going to be showing his
outfits and such in the background I'm
also gonna be doing that for the shaman
as well so not to discriminate but
regardless for our musha's outfits there
is a lots of customization on these
outfits those really nice colors and
definitely changes the hat and look as
opposed to the straw head you get a
little bit of a metal hat depending on
the type of higher gear that you are
wearing they just look very nice and I
have to congratulate the our team on
these they step it up every single
season with this stuff for the ornaments
and the weapons are Musha has lots of
bug looking ornaments as well as this
weird-looking demon with kunai in
between his fingers not entirely sure
what that's all about but regardless
definitely gonna have to pick that up
when I start playing our Musha and for
the weapons they look amazing some of
them have a serrated blade and some of
them even come with a golden color the
hilts on one of the weapons if you can
tell also has a ninja star which I
thought looked really cool and you can
also mix and match these so you can have
one of the swords with a serrated blade
even though the other one looks bright
gold which leaves tons of customization
for this character and that's really
about it next up is the shaman and
according to her description a reed
she's a wild cat on the battlefield uses
a dagger and a hatchet to slash and stab
her foes and overwhelming her opponents
she's a fast and predatory combatant her
special capabilities are fast strikes
short range bleed
and becomes more deadly when her
opponent is bleeding for her outfits she
also has a very diverse look of face
paint and hair once again depending on
the Alpha you choose some of her outfits
may have her have blonde hair some add
black and tons of other options like I
saw a nose ring and tons of other
piercings for one of the outfits so
there's tons of things for her for her
ornaments she has a very good looking
ornaments nothing too flashy compared to
our Musa but still nonetheless looking
very good especially the one with the
forged metal on top of it not entirely
sure what that's called but it does look
very good for her weapons she also has
some weapons they either have some gems
and rubies in it or engravings of Viking
language or symbols that also look
really nice as well now obviously these
weapons are going to be her axe and her
knife so I'm not entirely sure if you
can you know maybe have a gold or some
different type of axe or a different
type of knife I would assume you can and
mix-and-match just like our Musha is
once again for that customization feel
but nonetheless these do look beautiful
on top of that the old characters are
also getting new gear as well and some
of them some of the ones I caught during
the stream reward ins new skull little
gold looking sword conquerors Raven
shield that looks really amazing and
warlords new skull looking shield as
well now like I said all the new
characters got new stuff but those were
the only few I managed to screenshot if
you want to check the description for
the dev stream and there's also a time
step you can go to you can see your
favorite characters new gear as well so
beyond the hour be sure to check the
description for that and then lastly to
end this video at the start of season 4
there's going to be an upcoming patch of
1.15 which introduces lots of new things
like a new game mode tribute which we've
talked about multiple times on this
channel it got talked about about a
month ago and if you want to check that
just go to my channel there's a couple
more there's a couple videos on the
tribute mode so you can get caught up on
that new features coming to season 4 are
a fixing to load times which will
hopefully decrease the time to load a
match and find one especially during
that versus screen should takes like a
minute and a half just to start one a
new patching system which will hopefully
decrease the size of each patch so we
can have more space on our hard drives
for other games and other necessities
that we need as well as level 3 BOTS
spawning in games more often instead of
the level 2 BOTS but it all depends on
the skill level of the players in the
lobby there's also a ton of other No
but I'm only gonna be talking about the
important bit so don't worry once again
check the description should be right
below the devastating one there will be
a link to the patch notes if you want to
read along with me but for the important
parts health regen under one bar is
gonna be removed to discourage stalling
tactics like running away in turtling
late attacks are not gonna be
uninterrupted when the opponent is out
of stamina and key word is uninterrupted
not unblockable there are two different
things
next up rolling stamina now has been
increased from forty to fifty and no
longer has defense meaning you can be
guard broken while rolling also rolling
at the correct time will allow you to
avoid traps and roll through them like
the bear trap I'm assuming the nail bomb
and all that other good stuff as for
specific characters most of them are bug
fixes but law bringer has got one of the
few what is one of the few that had a
change in his range for his top-heavy
opener and chain a finisher are being
increased by roughly about half a meter
so nothing too huge but is definitely a
decent change for him
I don't play wahlburger so I'm not
entirely sure how the range will I might
have to ask why so the spliced on that
one but either way nonetheless it is a
small buff for the LOB ringer next up on
the patch notes is customization and
gear all heroes are receiving two epic
weapons and five legendary type weapons
as well as one heroic and one epic armor
variation there wasn't really much about
the customization in gear
it was just explaining that our emotion
and shaman are also going to be getting
their batch of gear but once again we
already knew that
next up now players are going to be able
to cook for executions at once instead
of two which I talked about last week
and a new thing called cloth embossment
which means you can now mold cloth parts
into armor and the engraving tab is
going to be renamed to embossed so that
you can now apply engravings to all
materials including cloth once again for
more customization type aspect and then
also is the ability to customize heroes
while waiting for a match which we have
been asking for for months and we're
finally getting it and then lastly for
this is the faction war faction war
phases now last eleven hours instead of
six the faction war camera is now going
to be from your factions point of view
as opposed to the original isometric
view of all three instead of a
percentage and now shows how many troops
affection has in a territory to
determine how close you are winning or
losing by on that specific territory
each territory now has been given a
unique name to give that more realistic
feel to the war and new areas are being
added to the map as well as 3d models of
troops being shown on the territories
and that was about it guys I hope you
did enjoy this tons of season 4 info
that just dropped maybe we'll get some
next week I will have no clue once again
be sure to be on the lookout for next
week's dev stream recap like always on
this channel and then one really quick
thing that doesn't really concern some
of the newer subs with some of the older
stuff so I remember a long time ago at
the release of season 3 I actually got a
copyright strike on one of my videos for
showing a leaked moveset of the
gladiator that were of the Highlander
that was completely my fault
but once again it is a copyright strike
and if it is November 9th which it is
today that means it is being lifted so
it's been officially three months the
copyright strike is gone and we're back
to normal
once again it doesn't really concern you
guys but just like to keep you guys up
to date the copyright strike has
officially been lifted but that is going
to officially be the end of the video
guys if you guys did enjoy please try to
give it a like it really does help me
out subscribe if you're new to my
channel I do a lot of for honor leaks
news of all the especially of season
four coming there's a bunch of news that
I've just shared and discussion videos
on other stuff regarding for honor my
two newest videos are going to be
popping up on the screen if you did not
check those out highly recommend you do
and other than that guys I hope you have
a great Wester your weekend and I'll see
you all later peace out